welcome to strange loop chats
i'm alex miller creator of the strange
loot conference this is a ongoing series
where we catch up with
previous speakers and other people
around the strange loop
universe today we have africa perrianez
who's
uh did a talk in 2019 at strange loop
called from video games to fashion a
machine learning jury
and we'll probably talk to her a little
bit about that and then
i want to talk to her about her new um
uh company that she's at called benshi
so welcome thank you
i your uh talk at strangely was kind of
a
personal journey of a lot of different
projects that you've worked on
um and it sort of started from
your science work at cern and then
german weather service and the weather
satellite prediction things
and then working at a few gaming
companies and then uh on to fashion so
um that's a a lot of different uh kinds
of things what's
what's similar about all of those uh
all of those kinds of projects so um
well indeed this is this is very
interesting so well for for
for more than i think 16 years now i've
been working in machine learning and
data science in
in different aspects um it was in um
when i was working in germany in the
numerical world prediction
in the um german weather service when
where i learned how to
um put modern models in production in a
way that they're
fully operational and real applications
can depend
on those predictions in this way it's
like
flights uh flight because of the
numerical world prediction system
of the operation in many countries
so so this is um well i was working
there with satellite data for a while
and then i moved to japan
uh to continue working with satellite
logs and
[Music]
and there i i realized that
this kind of um of operational settings
this kind of platforms are not available
in most of the industries okay so many
industries rely
still in traditional data science and
that they are basically based on reports
on data scientists paying
results to different business or or
leaders or stakeholders but why not
start putting this kind of operational
machine learning platforms with
scientific
running systematically so
[Music]
i was in japan and i started working in
the video game industry
i realized that uh well video game
industry was still
um in infancy regarding
machine learning and that also um
they they have probably one of the best
data sets
in the in terms of behavioral
user logs and and this is why
i started this this project cozuna data
which uh
it was on the spinoff of an spinoff of
silicon graphics
and and there we started building models
with the
with the logs of the of the players of
the of their company
and then we we built a machine learning
platform uh
ready to start ingesting um
logs from other multiple kind of games
so at the end we end up with a robust
machine learning platform that's able to
predict at individual level
what are the what are the rewards
to to give to every user which kind of
um
of content will be more suitable for
every every person
and be able to to engage them more into
the game and to
build better games at the end this is
what uh
what was probably one of the main pieces
then
i moved to to fashion
uh retailing where they are also
trying to to improve of course in many
ways
by tens cells etc with data science but
also they they want to to to improve
the engagement of their users in
online sales um with the
components of games okay so game designs
elements that that at the end are able
to
to create motivation in the users
and to engage them more on the apps
so um yeah so what it has in common
i i can say there are two two things one
is the
is the platform itself putting models in
production
so it's something that myself with with
my team
we are good at so when i do these moves
in my career
i was i was moving with parts of my team
that i was in
from i have seen from tokyo so then we
moved to
to inditex one of the largest
fashion detailing organization and and
it was when i was there
when when i started conversation with
the villain induced foundation
to to build a similar operational
machine learning platform to to
transport
state-of-the-art personalization
behavioral machine learning
to to improve global health outcomes so
at the end
is um taking
the best of them of being able to
understand
user motivations behaviors
at the individual level in a platform
and to be able to incentivize too much
behavior towards
different outcomes so so who's better at
making predictions
people are algorithms
that's a very good question um
i i would say um algorithms
so definitely so
[Music]
how is this sentence um i think was
almost versky who say it
man is a deterministic device thrown
into a probabilistic universe
so we are very bad doing predictions we
we are not able to our brain is not able
to generalize
well enough we are extremely biased
and what is worse of everything is that
we we think we feel we are not
so so that make us um
many times and i realize of myself of
course i have the same way of thinking
as everyone else
um that that take wrong decisions so if
you have a well-trained algorithm
use it so so we're very confident in
making very important
decisions or very poor predictions
yes yeah i mean of course the
there are um there's people with a very
deep knowledge
that are able to to of course make uh
make predictions but have data-driven
um database decision-form decisions
uh is is is crucial to to remove our
biases and
and to be able to utilize well enough
to to be able to just to foresee
objectively what is what is going to
come
so uh so now you're at this new company
called benchy
could you just explain a little bit
about what that is and how it
continues this kind of thing in a new
direction yeah so um
yeah banshee um is is born together with
the bellamy induced foundation so i was
working in
in fashion retailing machine learning
platform juicers
online users etc and
and well we have started conversations
in uh last year
um to to see how we can work together to
to bring this kind of technologies to
[Music]
to help in in global health outcomes to
to the most underserved communities so
what what is the goal the goal is to use
those logs
that are generated by telemedicine
online learning
apps and be able to to
to use this connection that that is
between passion
and care team from line workers to to be
able to provide
information in both sides to to improve
the quality
of the of the healthcare service so
so what we try to do at the end is a is
a better app
an app that that is used so
so the idea is to be able to to transfer
those those techniques that are common
in big tech companies
but bring them to to this whole
so the app is used by um
the people needing health care by
healthier workers
so the those hubs are
are used in in in most of the of the
lower middle income countries so in in
different ways and for different
purposes so
so there are there are apps that we are
working with for for midwives for
instance
that help them in terms of online
learning to
to improve their knowledge or others
apps are just for
pure diagnosis and to to support the
moment of the delivery
and before and after as well so
also any any app that that the patient
has to to follow up
treatment um apps that they are related
with telemedicine with diagnosis and and
prevention of diseases etc
so because of the of the ratio between
um
between doctrine and passion in in low
income countries
is very low so the this kind of hubs are
more spread that
even than in rich countries so
so at the end we end up with a lot of
logs
that bring a lot of information that can
be very helpful
to to help them to help mainly for
online workers but
also passions and at the end-notch
behavior towards
um prevention of diseases improvement of
the treatment
and uh and at the end improve wellness
in general
and and we believe that the impact of
this application can be tremendous
and in in management of any diseases
epidemiological diseases
um supply chains of also of
pharmaceutical products
etc and so a lot of
i mean i know there's a lot of concern
these days about bias and models and
things like that what do you what do you
do to control for that
for having models and bias and um
yeah so this is a very good question and
it's very important
um well i think that uh
probably the most the most crucial piece
is having a diverse team so that's the
that's
that's all about when when you have uh
um
most of the communities represented in
your team mainly when you are talking
about data scientists
they realize of things that otherwise
you never think of
and at the end those models are built by
by humans so
so they're going to data scientists are
going to do check-ups if for instance if
the data are biased that maybe if only
one type of
um of data scientists are building the
models that
maybe never think to do so to start with
the bias in the models the bias in the
data
so so this is what i'm trying we are
trying to do we are trying to
to build uh uh to build um a diverse
team where
we have we are able to attract african
talent
all kind of diverse or different
countries
mix also interdisciplinarity in terms of
um
in terms of disciplines so we have
theoretical statisticians computer
science data scientists
other kind of engineers data scientists
are coming from the
healthcare side from public health so
all mixed together
which is challenging okay because
diversity is
very um it's trendy now but of course
at the end you're mixing many cultures
and sometimes communication is back but
but but the first effort is worthy
because to build better products
and second in our case is crucial
because we need to be very close to
to to the communities we are working
with and um
and we cannot permit ourselves to to to
have bias models
so how did you get involved with the
bill melinda gates foundation
i know them i i met some part of the
team
in the past when i was working in the
video game industry
um so they they know about our work
uh in in terms of uh building
um personalized predictions
recommendations
uh put them in production be able to to
provide with this information
on real time also to to create um
interventions incentives and how to
motivate users
so that that is something that that
called attention of certain people and
um
and then they were looking for for
potential partners
to to do to build this kind of uh of uh
of platforms of systems and yeah
so that was the probably the connection
between
um yeah our background in video games
and building platforms together with we
can bring to the healthcare side
so i have the you talked about several
different algorithms
that you used uh in your talk and
a couple years ago is
what's a state-of-the-art these days are
those still relevant
algorithms and techniques or are there
new approaches coming out or what
definitely so now that we are starting
from zero
oh my god how difficult is that but
um yes um there are some models that we
will still use that they are very robust
and we tested so many times
that we feel very comfortable and um and
based on that maybe we are
growing in in new state of the art
incrementally
so all related with behavioral machine
learning sequential
um time series analysis time service
prediction because at the end what when
we are talking about behavioral machine
learning we are talking about
how how how behavior changes in
in time okay that's the most important
thing how certain interventions can
can make change behavior um change
habits
change actions so this is the kind of
algorithms that we are specialized
ourselves so so
so yes some of them we we still use so
what we are
moving um now um towards probably more
sophistication
is um is in the in the site of
experimentation
so because at the end what we are doing
with the machine learning models
is targeting users okay targeting
uh those people that uh those passions
that maybe are going to suffer certain
kind of diseases in the future
those patients that they are more likely
don't follow the treatment
those those patients or even those users
of the of the app that maybe stop using
it because there is not engaging enough
for them
so then we are going to lose the
connection so we won't be able to
provide with um
diagnosis or certain kind of
recommendations so
in this way okay so we are able to to
predict um
and to know what is the right time to
target those those those users
but um but this is this is what what we
are doing targeting
with machine learning models but then
with experimentation and gene that we
are building
so we are able to um effectively
effectively measure
what is the impact we are having with
the different actions to those people
that we are targeting
so we are moving um towards more
advanced technologies like micronumbers
trials
or contextual bandits
[Music]
experiments or reinforcement learning so
these are the kind of technologies that
we
we are implementing and putting together
with the results of the machine learning
models and
and put all these pieces together okay
so it requires
a lot of good decisions okay so it's uh
it's challenging uh piece by piece um
but the most challenging is like be able
to to
to build this platform in a way that
works well and was
smoothly able to to to provide
real-time um feedback
etc so yeah so this is what we are doing
right now
i can definitely see how they sort of um
using the models to predict behavior and
then you're
trying to influence that behavior to get
people to do things that'll help them
and
things like that i could definitely see
the ties
back to the video game industry and what
they're trying to do
although maybe for better purposes than
purely monetary purposes um
so it does how does that like when you
so that there is kind of a feedback
cycle there though that you're
you're tracking data and then using that
to try to um
nudge people's behavior into better into
different
um directions and then that obviously
feeds them back into
what you're seeing so that is that
something you have to
uh worry about or is that something
that's just takes care of taken care of
naturally by
having the models or things like that so
so first of all we of course follow the
the principle of no harm
okay so that's uh that we prefer don't
say
anything if there is any any any risk
of that can cause so hard but um
ourselves we are the providers of of
machine learning models of platform
centralized
repository of models of data etc
but um we are we are working with
partners
okay so we are a non-profit um but
uh but but we we will have clients we
have partners
so at the end we connect with different
kinds of apps and
and we work together towards the end
that that uh of course they are the ones
who
who knows they feel definitely better
than us so there are
um medical doctors they are um
very well um notch of all of the of the
field we are
working with i mean working with so
[Music]
so so we of course are sure that uh the
the goal that we are implementing
together okay
is the right goal so this is not
something that
ourselves we can we can judge and and we
don't want to
we don't want to do it so but um in any
case
of course no harm uh principle wins
that's uh that's for sure and also
an important piece of that of the
platform we are building
is that um is transparency so in every
moment
um all our partners are able to to see
all kind of validations
spline of all models of the features the
importance
all what we are we are working with they
have access
so there is uh full transparency on that
site and also in the
and in communication of the results so a
part of of course apis or sdks that
connect with every every server every
user
depends on the case so they will have
access also to the summary of
how many mods are in production when we
are sifting for an update
or just a better algorithm even how was
the performance of both
putting them in parallel for a running
with this model be
running with this other one what is that
the the success rate etc
so so that's that's the way that uh
first to gain trust of our partners
because they are the first that's if
they're not sure
they're not going to give this a step
forward and
and second to to be able to assure that
uh our predictions recommendations on
diverge
and they're not anything i mean doing
anything that is strange
so where does where is the um benchy
name come from
so well as as ourselves i mean our team
the core team no because now we are
growing and of course
adding new members um but
we started working together in japan so
we still
um wanted to use a a japanese name so
so we use banshee because when she was
um
was a was a profession that deceased in
all japan when um when the movies uh had
no sound
they had only subtitles most of them of
the japanese
were not able to to read so then they
went to the cinema and they were a
person that was explaining
for those that didn't know how to read
what was going on in the film
so so this is what we we try to do
okay we try to put some light we try to
explain what the data are saying
to to be able to the rest understand
what what is going on on the servers
that's a good name uh well i
i think this sounds fascinating and and
it would be great to have you back
strangely at some point in the future
and talk about what you're doing and
and uh the outcomes you're seeing and
and things like that so
um thanks so much for chatting with me
today and
and uh is there anything else you want
to share or anything you want to
else you want to share before we leave
no thank you very much
alex it will be a pleasure to speak
again in strange loop
and and i hope you heard more of us very
soon
okay great thanks a lot thank you alice